ارض هؤلاء المزارعين مهدده بالجفاف بفعل
التجاوزات للحصص المائيه على طولي نهر
الغراف والفرات في الناصريه جنوب العراق
وكلما توجهنا شرقا باتجاه الاهوار تزداد
المحنه ويصعب وصول الماء لهذه الاراضي ما
استدعى تقنين المياه من قبل الحكومه
العراقيه لتلافي الجفافه وتوفير المياه
الصالحه للشرب عن عظام احنا وين نعيش يعني
عندك شتوى كامله احنا ما وقعنا اكثر تموت
بها على الله
قديم الزمان يعني الدوله هسه قاعد تدور
وانا تطور والحديث وهذا يزيد معاناتنا
المرشات وما قالت هاي الحديثه
هي هي نحسبها مؤامره ما امره على الفلاح
بالنسبه للقرار السنه حسب راس الوزراء
وسمعناه يعني مو بحقنا يقول لك الطريق
الحديثه ليزرع
ماكو زرع الى
مواد الماء عده طريقه حديثه يعني المرشات
المرشات احنا مو ناجحه عندنا ارضنا طينيه
مراجعه ملف المياه داخليا ستشهد اجراءات
تتخذها الحكومه والتي تتمثل بمعاقبه
المخالفين وازاله البحيرات غير المجازه
وغلق منافذ مياه الصرف الصحي غير المعالجه
المسببه لاضرار بيئيه والزام الفلاحين
باستخدام نظام ري حديثه وفق توقيتات زمنيه
مقرره لجميع الوحدات الزراعيه عفوا هو
التحدي الاكبر اللي يواجه العراق عموما
ومحافظه ذي خصوصا هو تاثيرات التغير
المناخي والجفاف وهذا اللي اثر الى حدوث
حمائيه كبيره عن نبيها بالموسم الزراعي
السابق وكانت هناك بعض الحلول الانيه في
وقتها هو
القضاء على التجاوز على الحصص المائيه
بعد الاجراءات الداخليه تحشد الحكومه جهود
لاعاده تقييم الموقف المائي مع دول جوار
العراق لمواجهه موسم الصيف بخطه زراعيه
تضمن حصص مياه عادله لجميع المزارعين
وتتدارك توقف عمليات استصلاح الاراضي
الاعوام السابقه من الناصريه شاكر عواد
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات